foreign
foreign
the three Muslims we got brother Abdul
from the Warner here
Habibi look at that set up man mashallah
we got the Versace robe we got the
Moroccan top let's get into it man hey
alhamdulillah I'm trying to be the
freshest daddy in the game you know what
I'm
saying
mashallah bless you for all the work
that you do and for anyone that doesn't
know you right tell us a little bit
about your story you can toss as much as
you want to tell us as little as you
want bro you do your thing okay
absolutely absolutely well first and
foremost I just want to say thank you
guys so much you know for having me as a
guest on your platform it's a great
honor
um you know I've actually been watching
you guys prior to me being um you know
on YouTube uh before so I just want to
say you know it's it's a very beautiful
how everything comes full circle
alhamdulillah now I'm a guest on your
guys's show it's a very beautiful thing
I just want to say thank you guys so
much for having me and the may Allah
bless you guys may Allah reward you guys
for everything that you guys do for the
for the dean as well
foreign
let's do that for a lot of people
wondering right now is it pre-recorded
no this is not pre-recorded this is live
we're live we're standing one or Warner
Nation right now it's good morning
Nation let's go we in here let's go so
first question first question all right
let's let's do it so someone wrote what
is Warner Nation okay what is Warner
Nation so Warner Nation so inshallah so
the whole idea behind this right is I
want to create a nation of Warners right
a nation of people who warn people of
the truth right and and it is the harsh
bitter truth unfortunately right so I
want to create a nation of people who
warn people of the truth and bring
people to the truth as well because as
you know I'm not a Sheikh right I'm not
a scholar I'm a normal person just like
most of you guys watching today and I
want to prove to you guys and I want to
show it to you guys you do not have to
be a scholar in order to teach people
about Islam right the prophet saws says
that if you share if you you know one
verse share that verse so I want you
guys to know that you don't have to be a
scholar to go share The Message of Islam
that anybody can do this so inshaallah
once I am completing with my mission I
want every single corner of the United
States to have a die there blasting the
Quran handing out qurans inshallah by
the time I am done with my mission
inshallah this is what we want to
achieve inshallah
allow you to achieve that and even more
I mean I mean okay perfect so let's jump
let's jump right into it what is your
story begin man you can you can fast
forward or or rewind a little bit
whatever you want to do all right okay
absolutely absolutely so my story okay
it's actually a it's a pretty
interesting story alhamdulillah
um so I so first and foremost I was born
into a Muslim family right so my parents
are from Pakistan right uh so I was born
and raised into a Muslim family
um they came to America you know when
they were young and I was born and
raised in Los Angeles
so me being you know born and raised in
Los Angeles
oh no we lost them bro yeah sorry I got
a phone call coming in no no but yeah so
me being born and raised in Los Angeles
obviously it is very difficult
um practicing Islam in a non-islamic
environment and you know the earliest
memories I have of me trying to be a
good Muslim when I was younger is I
remember I was in Middle School and they
would see my mom drop me off like hey
why does your mom have a towel on her
head you know what I mean
um you know and they would ask me hey
why can't you eat pork you know I
remember After High School everyone
would go to the Carl's Junior everyone
hang out chill they would order their
food and I would always order fish and
thought they thought it was weird
because I would order fish you know but
every time they would ask me I had no
response I had no response like I didn't
know how to respond to all their
questions you know I realized that I was
Muslim by name but I had no knowledge of
the dean right and and I'm sorry to say
you know the way that I was taught the
dean I was very much pushed away from
the dean at a younger age because I was
forced everything you're forced to do
this you're forced to do that no
explanation I remember the first time I
went to the barber right and I got my
beard you know trimmed right I came home
and I got a nice slap in the face
no no explanation why nothing like that
just this is you know I mean so because
of these things it really pushed me away
from Islam and then obviously the whole
idea of 9 11 happened this this and that
and everybody portrays Muslims in a
certain way and me unfortunately because
I had no knowledge right I started
believing everything they said about the
Muslims so when I started getting into
that mentality I decided that you know
what I'm gonna push religion to the side
and I want to focus on my on the Dunya
right so at that time I wanted to become
a professional basketball player so I'm
about six eight six nine right
um so at that time I wanted to become a
professional basketball player so I was
so focused on basketball and I wanted to
make it to the NBA that was that was
what I wanted to do at that time and at
the same time you know I would bodyguard
you know uh you know I would you know I
started you know becoming I became like
a bouncer at the local uh like I would
be a bouncer at the local high-end uh
nightclubs in the area like in Beverly
Hills and Hollywood and stuff like that
so that's kind of like how I started
um you know in that uh in in that in
that security game right so I started
off you know as as a bouncer right
um in the high-end nightclubs they would
spend like 50 100K a night on the tables
and stuff like that right and I was
thinking that this is the life this is
the life that I wanted right at that
time I I stopped thinking about religion
I stopped thinking about these things I
was more trying to chase the worldly
life and a lot of the celebrities were
the people that I looked up to at that
time those were my role models and I was
shaking friends and I was walking around
with my role models right so as I was in
uh you know the security game for a
certain amount of time I started
becoming cool with a lot of the NFL
players a lot of the NBA players a lot
of the rappers a lot of the musicians
and I became close friends with them to
a point where I started bodyguarding for
them personally you know and now I am
fully integrated into that lifestyle
right and subhanallah you know as I got
integrated into that lifestyle
um I started you know and at the same
time I was chasing my basketball dreams
at the same time as well and then one
day I got injured and you know that was
the end of our basketball dream so I
started pursuing more of the
bodyguarding career for bodyguarding for
all these different celebrities and
stuff and as I was in that environment
right of being around you you know I'm
pretty sure you guys see on TV the
environment that the celebrities are
around it's a lot of drinking a lot of
partying a lot of drugs a lot of women
right so me being in that environment
alhamdulillah it was amazing because
obviously the the Islamic roots that I
had from the beginning still had a
positive effect on me because I knew
when I would watch them drink I knew
this is something that I would never
indulge in it just didn't feel like it's
something it just never felt right they
would always offer me a drink but I
always feel like uh no you know I mean
because obviously Even in our culture
we're more we're not drinkers even
culturally speaking are our you know our
culture we don't necessarily drink it's
not even within our culture so for me I
already knew this is a boundary that I'm
never going to cross right so I would
observe them you know how they would
like how my clients were in the
beginning of the night and how they
would end up and the end of the night
and this pushed me more to not ever want
to ever try alcohol ever because I would
see how it would turn people from you
know who they naturally were and then I
would see when they're intoxicated what
they would turn into right
um
so
I would see this every single night you
know I would bodyguard for my clients
about three four nights a week so almost
three four nights a week I would see
this beginning of the night you know
there's somebody they're they're they're
they're they're sober self they're their
natural self and at the end of the night
they're a completely different human
being so as I would observe this as the
years will go on I knew that this is
something I would never want to indulge
in because I would always be scared what
would happen to me if I start indulging
I'd become like them right so as I start
you know getting closer and closer to
these people as I get closer to this
environment
you know I started noticing certain
things you know certain weird behaviors
also I I can't necessarily get into
details of what I saw mainly because I
did sign NDA forms you know also a lot
of these guys still live nearby me so I
don't want to end up going missing you
know I mean but I did see a lot of
devilish activity I saw a lot of ritual
practices I saw that like the
confirmation of human blood I saw
certain things you know that I found
very appalling because to me
uh like these were the people that
everybody looks up to these were the
people everyone wanted to be like but
when I was around them they were the
most depressed people I've ever seen in
my life you know the things that happen
in their inner circles you wouldn't
imagine their friends are trying to
steal from them their family is trying
to steal from them nobody truly likes
them for they are they only want them
for what they could get out of them
right with the women they would come to
the house
as soon as they would fall asleep boom
they're stealing all the jewelry and
they're out you know it's just so much
chaos that nobody knows that's going on
behind the scenes because you know they
say this thing you know
um More Money More Problems so I saw
exactly what it meant by More Money More
Problems right and once you make to the
top how lonely he gets because I saw how
these people would abuse these
Superstars and all these celebrities and
I realized how depressed these
individuals were
so once I recognize how the person's
individuals were then and I started
realizing all the Satanic rituals and
the different practices that will go on
it made me come to a realization that
the devil is real so when I came to the
when I came to the realization that the
devil is real that shaytan is real then
I had to ask myself a real honest
question right if the devil is real that
means almighty God has to be real and if
the devil is real an almighty God is
real that means the afterlife is real so
I had to sit down and have to ask myself
am I prepared for the afterlife
and that's when I realized I wasn't
prepared for the afterlife and that's
when I went on my journey to find God
right so in the beginning of my journey
I started off with Christianity because
obviously I was already born in a Muslim
family and I was already pushed away
from Islam so I was like you know
obviously the Christians are so adamant
that they have the True Religion and for
some reason there's you know there is no
pushback for being a Christian it's easy
to be a Christian so I said okay let me
let me see you know let me see what they
got let me go ahead you know study the
scripture let me go ahead and spend some
time in the church let me see you know
what they're talking about as I started
getting deeper and deeper into
Christianity I started realizing like
subhanallah like wow this is actually
pretty crazy you know I mean like their
idea of who God Is Right their idea of
who the prophets were right and these
different things when I would try to
compare it to what I did know about
Islam I realized that you know something
about this message of Christianity is
not sitting right with my heart and it's
not sitting right with My Soul
so then I had to look at the opposite of
Christianity so I said I started looking
into uh Islam and I started studying
um Judaism as well so once I came to the
conclusion that you know as when it
comes to Judaism that you have to be
born a Jew like your mother has to be
jew in order for you to be accepted as a
Jew right that you can't necessarily
convert into a Jew it's more about
learning their Customs learning their
culture and stuff like that and I
realized okay Judaism can't be the True
Religion because it's only for a certain
group of people it's not yeah it's not
Universal yeah it's not for everyone so
I was like okay cool so I pushed that
away now Christianity so now I started
coming to to a point where I wanted to
challenge Christianity and see if it
holds up to you know the claims that
they make and anytime I would challenge
Christianity it would be dismantled and
it would fall so then I realized you
know I can't be a Christian because
their their beliefs have nothing strong
to stand on so then I started looking
into Islam I remember the first time I
actually read the Quran because I knew
surface
and but I never knew what it meant so I
remember I grabbed a English Quran it's
actually this Quran right here the clear
Quran I remember I grabbed this book it
was
I came back you know from bodyguarding
one of my clients
so I remember one night you know I came
back you know I came back from the club
and you know I was bodyguard one of my
clients and you know
and I I saw the Quran it was there in on
my kitchen counter right I had it for
some time but I never had the
opportunity to open it yet so I remember
I grabbed it I said you know what I'm
gonna open it I'm going to start reading
so as soon as I opened it and I started
reading I was sitting on my couch from
12 to almost fudger time right just
reading the book and I couldn't put the
book down I was so surprised that I was
born into this religion and I've never
ever read the Quran I knew Surah Fatiha
I I memorized these different chapters
of the Quran but I never knew the
translation of what it is that I said
and then when I realized man subhanallah
I started reading I started
understanding and I was like wow I was
so amazed that this was the teachings of
Islam so then I started getting very
very deep into Islam alhamdulillah then
I realized that Islam is the True
Religion so I decided that you know
Islam is the true religion and this is
the path that I want to be on as I got
closer to Allah I realized that you know
what as as a Believer and as a person a
warrior of Allah I cannot defend people
who are working for the shaitaan so I
came to a decision that I'm no longer
going to bodyguard for you know these
individuals that I did protect right and
you know I decided that you know I want
to get closer to Allah and I knew that
it was going to be a big test for me
because I would make almost about a
quarter million dollars from a part-time
job just bodyguard these different
individuals so I had to make a decision
right
do I want to because I knew if I was
going to be on this path of learning
about Islam getting closer to Allah this
and this opposite environment was going
to keep me away from that it was going
to completely keep me away from that
it's good to turn me from the path that
I want to be on so I decided to make a
decision that you know I no longer want
to be part of this and that I was gonna
I was gonna leave the bodyguarding I was
gonna you know kind of kind of restart
my life as a Muslim right
I started doing that and then as I would
do that you know I would you know I
would have different I would have a lot
of non-muslims friends right obviously
in Los Angeles it's a very um it's an
extremely large population but also the
Muslim population is very scattered it's
not all they're not all in one area
they're like scattered in different
areas so I wouldn't have too many Muslim
friends
so obviously most of my friends who are
Catholic they're Hispanic Christians you
know atheists different stuff like that
and you know as I was now this was the
point where I started studying Islam I
started you know practicing I started
learning more and I remember I came
across this
um you know this quote that knowledge is
useless unless it is shared so I decided
that you know what I want to share a
little bit of my religion with one of my
friends right I remember we were
chilling in a frat house right because
all my friends are in college and I
would chill with them at the frat house
right so we were all shooting at the
front house you know and then suddenly I
noticed it was time for prayer I was
like hey I would ask one of my friends
his name was Hector I said hey do you
mind if I go pray in your room real
quick you know it's it's time for me to
pray he's like yeah sure can I pray with
you and I was shocked I was like what do
you mean you want to pray with me he
said yeah I want to pray with you and I
was like uh I was like yeah sure come
through you know I mean so so I told him
you know what you just have to do your
will do he started doing his wudu and he
stood next to me I explained to him what
we're gonna do and then we started
praying we started praying together and
then once we heard the recitation of the
Quran once he performed this first
sajdah right and then after we were
finished with the Salah you know I I
turned and looked at him and I saw the
peace on his face
and I saw like how how amazing he felt
and how happy he was that he joined me
in this prayer it made me realize that
subhanallah why am I shy
why am I shy to be a Muslim look how
it's affecting this brother who has no
idea what about it whatsoever he's
involved with all the women you know you
know how it is in the Frat houses you
know it's just parties girls all that
you know so a person like that wants to
get away from that and get closer to
Allah so it kind of solidified more in
my belief that listen I'm doing the
right thing and then finally
you know a few weeks later the brother
took a shahada after he took ashada then
next you know the other brothers in the
frat house they wanted to start also
participating in the prayers as well so
I would come once a day twice a day and
we would pray together and then more and
more brothers would start joining and
then it came to a point to the whole
fraternity came to Islam one by one
alhamdulillah and it was so crazy
because I remember certain Brothers they
would get so upset when they would hear
us saying Islam while they come to each
other you know like you know obviously I
would walk in the house everyone says
like it was like a bunch of Hispanics
Islam
you know but some of them didn't like to
see their friends chasing in a positive
you know way so then they slowly stopped
drinking they stopped like certain type
of habits just solely slowly I would
never tell them to stop it it would
naturally happen by themselves as they
would get closer to Allah slowly slowly
they didn't want to do the things that
they were involved when previously right
so that's just a little bit background
I'm not gonna lie there is a lot more
details but you know uh that's just a
short uh glimpse of kind of like how I
started giving dawa how I started
realizing that Islam is the True
Religion mainly by seeing the reaction
of the non-muslims right and seeing how
when they did come to Islam how they
would change in such a positive way I
would see all like I would see them you
know right when they take their shahada
and then you know months later now
alhamdulillah different they're getting
job opportunities you know different
blessings are coming into your lives you
know
um they're just upgrading in lifestyle
like subhanallah I'm witnessing all
these different blessings that these
people are are attaining from Allah so I
realize how much how positive The
Message of Islam was based on the people
I was sharing it with and that's what it
really solidified my belief that Islam
is the true religion
honestly honestly probably one of the
best stories I've heard 100 100 like I
can't even believe it's real that's so
touching masha'allah I I don't want to
put it on that level but it's you know
those stories you'd hear from like the
time of the you know the salaf and the
sahaba and the time of like the
classical Scholars those amazing Stories
because these people were close to Allah
they would experience beautiful things
amazing things with their people their
communities you know it's like one of
those stories it's like a man walks in a
room like everyone converts you know
something crazy like that's final that's
it's it's mind-blowing Masha Allah so
when did you decide that okay I need to
open up a booth and give dawa to you
know people who are just going to like
enjoy the beach or whatever because
Santa Monica is like iconic bro everyone
knows Santa Monica is a place to go
chill out you know yeah yeah no
absolutely absolutely so one so I so
I've been doing this like as far as
giving dawa to the allow muscles I've
been doing this for years right and then
when I would come across like you know
these different stories like of how
these people end up finding Islam their
their path to Islam their shahada is
like bro I would remember bro it's you
know what to me I would say you know
like how they say the best way to learn
is to teach right so what I would
recognize like these different Brothers
you know for instance there was this one
brother his name is Brian we call him
b23 right I remember when he first came
to Islam he was actually a very he was a
very um
you know a very loyal Christian right he
was a very very loyal Christian he was
always God fearing he was like one of
the Bros in the frat house that would
always talk about God right but he would
never connect with any of the Bros the
way that he would talk about God you
know because obviously you know the
Christian way of preaching unfortunately
it doesn't touch the heart bro it really
doesn't unfortunately you know what I
mean so you know you know and then I
knew that we had a connection you know
we both talk about God he wanted to ask
me more about Islam
right I remember the first time after he
took a shot of that he wanted to come to
the Masjid
you know the certain things that would
happen to these people he came he tried
to come for Fajr right as he came for
fudger he came as soon as he was about
to walk into the I walked into the door
randomly this a half-naked woman is at
the Masjid door trying to not let her
let him come in saying oh my daughter
got kidnapped I need your phone can I
borrow your phone and keep in mind
brother like you have to press a lock
pad to get into the Masjid you know
there's a long path to get into the
Masjid to get to the front door also
keep in mind it's funder time you know
there's no strangers walking around that
area on the bus half naked you know uh
asking for your phone right so as he's
about to walk into the Masjid
you know there's this half naked woman
that comes up to him and tells them hey
can I borrow your phone you know my
daughter got kidnapped so he's like oh
wow like it's like five in the morning
and some woman just you know comes up to
him like this she said yeah sure so now
you know it's now you know she's trying
to call her daughter and then suddenly
she switches the conversation to
something else oh why are you going in
there
oh like you know like now she starts to
switch the conversation he's like wait I
thought your daughter is kidnapped why
are you asking me why am I going to the
Masjid right and then suddenly my father
was in the Masjid as well right and he
saw this lady
and then he saw Brian and as my dad
started walking to her my the lady saw
my dad and then suddenly she like you
know uh she she gave the phone back she
turned the corner disappeared
bro that's shython bro
like I didn't realize
how the shaitan State operates you know
I didn't understand
that I threw all these new Muslims I
would recognize wow how the shaytan
operates like how literally he he tries
to stop you any weekend that was his
first time ever coming to the Masjid
right and literally the shaitaan came in
the form of a half naked woman right to
try to stop him from entering to the
doors of the Masjid you know and I
didn't know these things were possible
like I had no idea about this whatsoever
so sorry now I started studying more
start studying more and then I started
recognizing all these different things
so Paula one of our Bros he actually was
possessed with a shaitaan in him and he
was the same bro that hated anytime it
was Islam while they come to one another
and I would recognize later that it's
only the shaitaan the hate of what we
were doing it wasn't him and so later on
he ended up taking shahada but it was
just so crazy bro just I have stories
for days bro when it comes to this stuff
I have stories for days you know what I
mean but it's just absolutely insane and
I you know for me as I was giving dawa
I started realizing like how important
The Message of Islam was and as I was
getting more and people to accept Islam
then the shaytan started attacking me
you know and then I started realizing
the tax started coming on me you know I
remember this one night I was in my room
and you know I felt a presence of
something right
and literally it was crazy like I I felt
the presence of something right so I
woke up and it's like you could see like
it's like nothing but energy it's like
just covering the whole world not the
whole world my whole room it was covered
in like a fizzy type of energy like you
could see through it right but it's all
blurry right
and I go I got my bed and I said hey
I've been waiting for you
I thought his neck was and I grabbed it
because and it's just so crazy because I
knew that was the shake on trying to
scare me you know trying to say like oh
you know like you know trying to show
its power to me and try to present
itself to me in a way where I'll be
scared but you know I only fear a lot
bro I am not scared of the creation of
Allah I only fear the Creator and once I
started realizing yo the shaitaan
doesn't like me he's trying to stop me
from doing certain things then I
realized that listen I I what I'm doing
is actually deeper than what I thought
it was I'm going to war with the
shaitaan and when I recognize that I am
going to war with the shaitaan I started
preparing myself for war bro you know
what I mean so and uh yeah I'm the line
I actually really enjoy it going to work
which they thought it's a beautiful
thing bro it's a very beautiful thing
man because you have no idea how many
people were saving from the grasp of the
shaitaan it's truly truly amazing
it's weird too when I deal with a lot of
people in the community it's like it's
almost like their lives were seemingly a
little bit less you know
shaitan or gin field you know a little
bit less drama and then the second they
want to come deeper into Islam bro
game over you know exactly and you know
that's when I started recognizing the
psychology of the shaitaan there's a
saying right
you must know
so that's why I started started learning
you know trying to learn more about the
shaitaan who is the shaitaan the
psychology of the shaitaan and how he
operates and how he works and that
really helped me about how I communicate
with the different people like what I
would see their reactions I know okay
the shaytan just whispered in his ear
right now like I just recognized like I
could recognize these things now like I
could see what's happening in in the
spiritual world based on you know my
previous experiences but as far as you
asking me what inspired me to go out and
publicly give dawa it's actually quite
interesting was actually a great great
motivation for me to go and do it right
but it wasn't just right that motivated
me
um because you know like I said before I
would always give dawa and I would have
these Amazing Stories right and I just
thought like man I have to share these
stories with the world because I
realized how much it was boosting my
Iman and the people I would share these
stories with how much it would boost
their mind as well and I would see
Sheikh Cubana out there I'll always
watch his videos and subhanallah he was
this great inspiration for me right but
you know that was like one of the steps
you know that like as far as like
watching him I knew what to say how to
react you know how to respond I learned
a lot of that from him but as far as the
courage to go out and do it I'm not
gonna lie Andrew Tate is the one who
inspired me and gave me the courage to
do what what you know I know this is
actually yeah go ahead go into that bro
go into that tell us tell us go into
that yeah yeah but it was actually
Andrew Tate that inspired me and gave me
the courage to do what needed to be done
because I remember I was listening to
him right and he said that listen we're
not
the real pandemic that we're facing is
we're living in a pandemic full of
cowards and then when I realized that
like wow men are no longer men men have
become cowards that no longer Brave I I
you know I turn off the TV and I asked
myself am I a coward am I scared right
and that's when I realized you know what
no I'm not scared I'm not a coward and I
have the courage to do what needs to be
done and so all from that day I changed
my Instagram name from you know Abdul
wahab to I am the Warner and then boom
the next week I went out there and then
began Man On The Run
this is better than like Game of Thrones
man Masha Allah
[Laughter]
that's amazing man that's amazing so
tell me about your first do you remember
your first experience when you put this
stand up and the first person that came
up to your desk do you remember what
that was like
ah honestly no bro it's been it's been a
couple of months now so I don't
necessarily remember so my first
experience so uh what my idea was is
that I was just gonna publicly recite
Quran I didn't know exactly what I was
gonna do but I was just like in a mode
where like listen like I need to do what
needs to be done like you know I was
just I was just a certain point that you
know I need to do no more talking all
action I need to be like straight up
action everything I say I'm gonna do it
so I started off
um I think I would I went to Santa
Monica pier and I just started reciting
Quran publicly you know and I would have
some qurans right in front of me and
then people will grab but I wasn't
necessarily you know doing it the same
way I'm doing right now where I'm
teaching people I'm you know talking to
people this kind of came naturally
afterwards you know but that was like
this little progression of where it is
right now but in the beginning all I
knew is I had to go out there I had to
show that I had you know like the
cojones to do what needs to be done you
know I had the I had the courage right
to do what needs to be done right
um
and then you have somehow I just started
off you know reciting the Quran publicly
and then I would see their reaction and
subhanallah I would go out there all by
myself bro I don't want myself I'll go
out there you know and you know
obviously you know alhamdulillah I'm
about six seven six eight you know um
you know uh trained martial artists I'm
not I'm not tripping about anyway anyone
could pull up on me I'm not tripping you
know like I actually dare them to pull
up on me because they'll see what
happened to them you know what I mean
but you know so like you know I wasn't
worried about that but subhanallah as I
would recite the Quran you know I would
see you know different Muslims like come
like behind me just to protect me like
they see what I'm doing and they were
just kind of like they're in the corner
like just waiting just in case someone
does do something so I would see him at
subhanallah like how Allah is sending
reinforcements you know like I see it
happening and I I just realized that
listen this is something that I really
really want to do and then I started you
know thinking of more ideas you know how
can I do this in a better way like what
is the best way that I could share The
Message of Islam with these people right
and to me to be honest I'm not much of a
debater right I'm more of a
conversationalist I I like I I love
people and I love connecting with people
so I thought that I should stick to my
strengths and just connect with people
and just talk to people you know so
that's from the law that's something
that I always enjoyed I truly love all
people because I believe that we are all
the children and we're all related some
some way somehow so I always had this
love for people in my heart you know and
I knew that a lot of these people were
misguided and that once they heard the
truth in a very clear and succinct
manner that inshallah hopefully if their
heart is pure that Allah will guide them
foreign
and based on you saying that man you're
not a debater now I'm even more curious
to know you know all the tips you have
and and and advice you have for giving
SRI dollar because a lot of people let
it too easily get turned into a debate
bro too easy exactly you know me
personally too I want to ask you this
question because you mentioned that your
conversationalist you want to have a
heart to heart how do you balance that
heart to heart when there's
disagreements and you know you see
things that are not true that the other
person's saying and you really want to
like kind of change their views and
challenge them in a way so how do you do
that without getting debated
absolutely I mean it says very clearly
in the Quran right Bismillah
[Music]
[Music]
right it says in Surah
uh in chapter
109 of the Holy Quran uh chapter the
called the disbelievers Allah says very
clearly in the name of Allah the most
compassionate and most merciful right
all you disbelievers I do not worship
what you worship nor do you worship what
I worship I will never worship what you
worship nor will you ever worship what I
worship you will have your way I will
have my way
and once I realize that listen you know
our job is not to convince people our
job is simply to portray a message Allah
does the rest but it is our job to use
our intellect to use our god-given
abilities and our gifts to portray the
message as clear and as beautifully as
we possibly can and then Allah will do
the rest so when they do disagree with
me I said no problem my dear brother you
have your beliefs I have my belief I
just want to share with you what the
Muslims believe because most people know
what Christians believe but they have no
clue what the Muslims believe so I have
a way and also keep in mind I've been
bodyguarding for many years so I know
how to denutralize situations very
easily it's not hard for me to do
denutralize the situation you know I've
been in tons of fights like brawls 50
100 men brawls so bro I know how to
handle myself in Crazy situations bro
like bro I got stories bro
but we're gonna have to do a whole other
episode just stories with the Warner bro
forget episode bro we gonna have to do a
whole season with this brother bro and
next time we come to La bro off camera
thing for sure hey let's go let's do it
man
I actually want to share with you how I
came up with the name the warmer the
Warner do you mind if I share with you
guys so far man no I remember one day
right um
that you know to recite uh Surah
um
uh what was it sort of milk every single
night right but I never read the
translation of Surah malt so I remember
one day you know I sat down I started
reading the translation of Surah milk
right and then it says in Surah milk
right
chapter 67 right
um I'll go ahead and recite the verses
I'll I'll translate it as well right it
says
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right it says right that every time a
group is cast into the Hellfire its
Keepers will ask them did a Warner not
come to you and they will reply yes a
Warner did come to us but we denied and
said Allah has revealed nothing and that
you are extremely astray and they will
lament oh
we had listened and reasoned we would
not be amongst the residents of the
Blaze and so they will confess their
sins so away with the residents of the
blaze so when I read that verse I
realized that subhanallah Allah has been
using me to warn all these different
people of the truth and especially so
many different young people bro
literally it was so crazy because once
the first brother took it was like a
wave bro it was like boom Another
another and actually no bro it just was
like it was a crazy like effect that was
happening like one after another after
another after another you know and it
was just like subhanallah Allah is like
I I recognize Allah is using me and I
felt so grateful to Allah like wow like
Allah is using me he doesn't spread the
Deen like then that feeling bro that I
felt like wow like I felt so close to
Allah bro I felt so close to Allah like
and I wanted other people to feel that
feeling as well because I felt so I felt
so Unstoppable bro like I just felt like
a like an Unstoppable Force that no one
could stop me you know I just felt like
Untouchable you know I wanted other
people to also feel this feeling
Allah Allah that's so beautiful although
that's so beautiful
I wanted to say I can relate to that but
I mean honestly not not even to that
scale subhanallah like to for me it's
like I was always
and I went to a Catholic school so I was
talking you know some Christians
that's all for me Allah that is
absolutely beautiful have you done like
an episode or something about your story
because if you haven't you need to in
depth no I I am inshallah I am so
actually in trouble what I'm gonna do is
right now I'm focusing on the street but
basically what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
start a podcast as well where I'm gonna
start I'm gonna interview all the
Muslims that like where I started from
the first shahada all the way to now
right and then basically you know I have
this idea where I want to prove to
people that Islam is a positive thing
look everyone needs Islam everyone needs
the Quran and everyone needs to know who
the prophet Muhammad is and I'm going to
prove it to them with video evidence to
show how people's lives has changed in
such a positive way just by the message
and I'm going to prove it to them bro to
a point where they might kick me out of
America bro because I'm gonna really
prove a point Margie you know what I'm
saying
watches it he's gonna get the same thing
bro it's a little bit late for him in
France it's past midnight right now so
he's probably fast asleep but uh that
brings us to my next question insha
Allah
when you're giving Street dawa right
what are some of the main I guess themes
or patterns you've picked up on thus far
you know for example
um one might argue that when you're
giving dawah to Christians right a
common theme is just dispelling the
Trinity right just proving the the
Unicity or the tawheed right just
Oneness of Allah so what is something
you've commonly found in the
demographics of you know in Santa Monica
and just the LA population
so um
so what I found is obviously La is a
pretty Godless City bro it's a very
Godly City obviously Hollywood is is the
center of all
you getting a call again
I think so I think so or it's shaitan
bro oh okay yeah I think you blanked out
for a second actually I wanted to
actually share another reason another
thing that really inspired me I remember
one time I came back from umrah right I
came back from umrah
and I was actually in Makkah right so my
first time going to Makkah right I went
to Makkah and I was like wow this is
such an amazing pure environment and
literally when I was leaving the Cabo I
started crying so much because I was
coming back to L.A and I was like no
what
why because I was just
a secure environment right so I decided
to myself like listen
the only reason I'm gonna live in a
country like this is to share the truth
with the people because what better
place to share The Message of Islam than
a Place full of Darkness
right you know what I mean what better
place than to do it right here in
America you know where people are so
lost people are unhappy people are you
know trying to find purpose people are
trying to find truth but they're so
distracted with all the different types
of entertainment that the world has to
offer you know and and then they never
get to truly get a moment of silence to
ask themselves the real questions you
know so I wanted to be one of the you
know I wanted to be kind of like a you
know a person who starts a movement of
spreading the truth but doing it in in a
beautiful manner right but regarding
your question as far as you know
dispelling the Trinity I actually don't
do any of that you know when when the
Christian brothers and sisters do come
to me and they they explain to me they
believe this is not I'm not there to
shut down their beliefs if they want to
choose to believe that no problem I am
simply here to teach you about Islam I
want you to hear the message of Islam
we're not going to argue back and forth
there's no arguments that are going to
take place right if you want to argue
that's fine I'll demolish you because
the arguments I'll have will destroy you
immediately but I'm not here to do that
I'm here to share with you the message
of Islam alhamdulillah being a giant
does help you know
that does help I have a certain demeanor
that people know not to mess with me you
know I mean I just have a certain
demeanor the way I carry myself they
know okay it's probably not the guy I
want to mess with you know what I'm
saying
um so they definitely you think about it
but I have a certain way of talking to
them where I'm simply here to share The
Message of Islam to you I'm I make it
fully aware that listen I know the
message of Christianity I'm aware of the
message of Christianity but I'm here to
teach you about Islam and that Islam is
actually the true way and the true
guidance but obviously they can only do
that through education that's why I give
them the Quran that's why I hand them
the different books that I hand them
it's through education hopefully they
will recognize that what they believed
in and what they've been taught is
nothing but lies and they will recognize
that Islam is the truth but through
knowledge through knowledge that's what
I want to do I remember
um you know I'm actually alhamdulillah
you know uh so anytime I you know so
alhamdulillah when I remember the first
time I went to Makkah I ended up meeting
are you guys familiar with Muhammad of
course man of course
and I ended up you know getting close to
him so I talked to him you know uh
pretty often you know uh you know I get
to see her from different stuff like
that and I remember you know I would
tell him oh you know you know spreading
Islam this is uh this major holidays I
was very excited oh I wanted to just
like keep getting more Hondas more
challenges I was like kind of like
racking up your holidays right it was
like kind of like a game right and then
he told me no no no it's not about the
quantity but the quality of Believers
and then he changed my whole mindset now
I actually I no longer change shahadas
right my main thing is I want to educate
people on Islam on what the what we
believe like I want you to at least if
you're going to explain our beliefs to
other people explain it the right way I
want you to hear the right things
because most people all they know is the
lies of Islam they don't know any of the
truths of Islam all they know is the
lies of Islam
right so at least I'm trying to you know
take control of The Narrative of sharing
the true Message of Islam
mashallah bro that's so true because you
know when you think about a lot of the
people in the west and I was asking
Angel this too because Anna's an
American revert mashallah he accepted
Islam about just under two years ago
closing it on two years now and when I
asked him I was like bro where did you
get most of your preconceived notions
about Islam from he was like everything
I knew about Islam not for Muslims bro
from Fox News or the media or what they
taught him in school what his teachers
taught him you know people that he knew
in his community there was no Muslims
absolutely absolutely like all these all
these uh like false allegations that you
hear about Islam all the lies I hear
about Islam is from people who are
profiting off Christianity to be honest
if you want to if you want to get right
to the point most of the people who
dispel lies about Islam is because
they're profiting of Christianity and
they know Islam is going to basically
get rid of all their monetary gain
because we know Christianity is a
business we know it's a business right
so they're they know Islam it gets rid
of the business of Christianity so it's
mainly the people who are profiting off
the the falsehood of Christianity they
have to do whatever they can to dispel
Islam because Islam is messing with
their money
um
it's all about money at the end of the
day man it's all about the money
hmm
that's what there's this whole movement
called dcci in the UK I'm sure you know
about that right no no I'm not familiar
with it so people like David wood
attuned their their big proponents of
dcci and the whole movement stands for
defend Christianity critique Islam but
you get the all these people that you
see the ones that are one of the biggest
islamophobes you'll see a large majority
of them aren't trying to get you yeah
some of them are trying to get you to
leave Islam and come to atheism but a
good amount of them are trying to get
you to leave Islam and come to
Christianity people like Nabil Qureshi
all these people people are part of dcci
and the thing that I find profound is
the amount that they get through patreon
through donations through the church
they're not gonna get that bro with with
a lot of people becoming Muslim and just
like you said people are profiting off
of the false pretense of Christianity
right and they can't have Islam with
that even capitalism bro even looking at
a society Society itself will not have
this imbalance power Dynamic you know
what I mean with the elites and everyone
else is just slaved and and poor you
know it's not going to happen when
people understand
and they break up
so you know even looking at the way
everything works bro and I don't want to
go too much you know because you say too
much you're gonna get you're gonna get
blocked out of this platform but
absolutely um I think that with snico
with Tate you know you know with
everybody look what's happening to them
bro you you speak some truth next you
know you're gone it's crazy bro crazy
and and Savannah that's why like you got
to play with him you got to play the
game but you got in the rules and what's
what's the line and never cross that
line you know and a lot of people
subhanallah a lot of people this is a
side thing you know but a lot of people
that are that are part of the audience
they don't have YouTube channels or
anything they're gonna hate on you for
doing so they're gonna be like oh why
don't you say this why don't you say
that bro I tell you you want to do
better you do better start a paneling
yourself a massive following try to do
that and see how far you can get away
with just being and just you know just
out there not saying this was actually
very interesting that you brought that
up because I'm not gonna lie I would
watch a lot of these different download
channels and I'll say oh man you could
have said it like this you could have
done it like that and I would think that
in my head and I was like yo why would I
just go out and do it myself like Allah
has given me a fully functioning body I
have a tongue that works I have a brain
that works right I have ability to
comprehend and attain some knowledge why
don't I go out there and do it myself
right so it really you know it's
unfortunately we live in the society
where most people are Watchers they're
not doers and this is the big problem
bro it's a big problem people will watch
other become people become successful
and and just drown in their own failure
you know it's very unfortunate
yeah it's unfortunate but that's that's
exactly what Society aims to produce you
know since your birth you know obeying
your parents is fine is one thing but
they put you in an institution you have
to obey the teacher and you're in that
Institution for years and then you go to
college same thing uh you're always
trying to basically please the people
above you and work for them and and then
you go to work and the same exact thing
they're they're literally breeding
people to sit there and do work and
listen it's it's kind of cringe to say
but but people are Bots bro there's
literally way to say it and like the
second you have you're like the black
sheep the second you have any type of
you know dissenting you know loan type
of view on anything else you're
automatically like gonna be use shaming
tactics you know you're a misogynist
you're an extremist you're this you're
that and like people gotta know like
when we're doing the dawa we're not
trying to water down to that one no
one's trying to water down the theme but
there's a specific Niche or way of
saying things and if you you kind of
fall out of that you deviate from that
that's it bro no platform and you gotta
ask yourself what's better having a
platform form or losing your platform
just because you want it to sound like
you know the big guy yeah and I want to
comment on something before it slips my
mind I don't believe what anyone here is
trying to say is that everyone who gets
banned was speaking the truth there are
definitely people who are just
misogynistic people who are just evil
women who are just misandras who just
hate men right there are these people
out there and these people get shut down
and stuff as well what we're trying to
say is that when you look at the Muslims
right you look at those giving down
whether they're living in you know a
Muslim country or an Amazon country one
way or another according to unjust
rulers or a an unjust ruler they may be
locked up they may be shut down they may
be like I don't obviously don't agree
with everything Andrew Tate says but his
his Airbnb account why take his Airbnb
account
to me that was crazy when I heard they
went after his bank account like more
than just social media they're literally
trying to silence you but obviously with
what I'm trying to do I need to possibly
be prepared for the same thing you know
because I I really want to start a big
movement bro a big movement a real big
Awakening of Islam in the United States
inshallah
and this this man well this this is so
inspirational along with that it really
is because we need Muslims to you know
be men we need Muslims to be go-getters
because if no muslim if no muslim is a
go-getter then Islam will not be spread
and you hear this common narrative a lot
when it comes to you know the hilafa and
Islamic rulership and Islamic governance
when people say there's no good rulers
and you know people respond with no more
one day Allah will bring us a good ruler
one day you know like yes everything
happens if Allah Wills you know if I
speak on this podcast it's because Allah
Wills if I go on pray my Salah because
Allah Wills something like Salah I can't
say oh I didn't pray Allah didn't will
it I still have to go and do it myself
right and same thing with dawah that was
an obligation upon the Muslims it like
the brother mentioned that Hadith he
said convey for me even if this is one
Ayah meaning if all he knows that's all
you know go go you better share that you
better
exactly 100 well and recite it just like
the brother Allah to the people let them
know alhamdulillah you could break
literally you could do a tough state of
that and spend 10 minutes of their time
teaching them about that one Ayah that's
how encompassing the Quran is so you
know when people say these things like
oh one day Allah will bring these people
let me let me teach you something let me
teach you something actually Allah is
going to teach you something he says in
the Quran Let There rise from basically
the ummah from the nation a group all
right he talks about a group that calls
the good a group that does good you know
and in in Surah he talks about the
forerunners
and if you want to be a forerunner you
don't wait till Allah makes you one
because Allah is not going to make you
one unless you work to be one so we have
to be go-getters right that's why we
start to keep in mind it's through
walking also said that the foremost the
forerunners There Will Be Few
from later generations but many from
previous generations
subhanallah
yeah go ahead continue sorry no I think
that's that no that's good 100 percent
because that that speaks volumes to the
point that we don't have enough and you
know actually another Hadith
he said I forget the context but there's
a Hadith
that right now there's a lot of
knowledge
so action is preferable action is what's
needed basically right he said there
will come a time where there's there's
basically there's lots of you know
speakers and dies and so on and so forth
but very little knowledge I mean you're
gonna have a lot of people a lot of
speakers they'll get up on the stage and
have a beard and they'll say whatever
they want to say whether it's correct or
incorrect whatever
actually if anything the process the
process is inferring that they might be
incorrect because there's very few
Scholars very little knowledge so right
now what we need to do is we need to
learn our Islam we need to learn our
Deen and we need to learn what a Deen
actually is I don't want to go on too
long but we have to learn what a Deen
actually is because before you go out
and do what you know um what uh brother
uh Abdul wahab right that was a little
obviously I didn't want to call you
brother the Warner but before you go out
and do what the brother's doing you have
to understand that a Dean is a full way
of life and it will change the way you
think ideologically and I don't I'll
stop there because I don't want to go on
too long about ideologies and that stuff
but it Islam will literally
ideologically from your perspective how
you see the world change your life and
until you go through that change and
until you go through that shift
you know you're not really in that space
to even give that one so focus on that
learn your knowledge and go out and
teach the world inshallah yeah and also
you know uh you know you we were just
talking about the people right who get
paid to slander Islam right we have to
understand why like you know one thing
on my journey of finding the truth I
remember every single day right I would
have I would have a notebook next to my
bed right and I would write down the
questions that I wanted answered that
day every single day I would wake up
with questions I did this for almost 10
years right every single day I would
wake up boom write the questions I
wanted answered right like things that I
needed to be get figured out right and
that whole day I would go and find the
answer and then the next thing I wake up
new questions new answers right I did
that for many years to appointment now
I'm comfortable now I know I know enough
to feel like okay alhamdulillah I know
like whatever I know I'm I'm solidified
in what I know alhamdulillah and I
understand why you know I understand why
you know that's the biggest question why
are they slandering Islam why and the
answer will very much shock a lot of
people the reality is why they attack
Islam because Islam will destroy the
banking system Islam will destroy the
alcohol industry trillion dollar
Industries banking industry the alcohol
industry the fashion industry right all
these immodest women right all these
baby mamas and baby daddies it's going
to be dismantled bro we're gonna have
fully functioning strong families they
don't want that because if you come with
a strong family a strong leader you're
no longer looking up to celebrities
you're looking up to your father
you're no longer looking up to the
president you're looking up to the
leaders of your family the ones who are
right in front of you not the people on
the television right there's many
reasons for it right the banking
industry the alcohol industry the
clothing industry right all these
different Industries right are profiting
off the gambling industry right there's
many different industries that profit
off Islam not prevailing because once
Islam comes these industries will no
longer exist and guess what they profit
off people's Sorrows off people's
depression you know they're just trying
to take advantage of people but they
have a way of shaytan has a way of using
the most beautiful people to advertise
this message
and we always fall for it bro we always
fall for it bro
100 you know I'm actually currently
taking a a culture and media course and
subhanallah it's crazy because what you
just said reminded me of a question they
asked us to write a little like summary
on or a little uh you know our thoughts
on basically and they asked which of
these uh tactics that media uses to
basically I forget the wording but you
know promote some kind of propaganda or
to basically deter you away from reality
or to convince you of something which is
the strongest and they gave a whole
listen I looked at it and I'm like bro
this one and the one that I picked
and I think the one that is the
strongest is is creating problems and
offering solutions that is like bro
that's a like a triple-ended sword just
being jammed in you because they make up
they make they either make a problem for
you or they make you think you have a
problem so you're in a State of Shock
panic I need help you know it's like
when the when the government says we
have a great enemy thus wants to destroy
us and blah blah blah you're gonna look
like freak out be like bro you know this
country wants to destroy us what am I
going to do you're in a state of panic
and in the country you're living in will
provide the solution for you and they'll
save you and then you'll be so thankful
to them you'll love them so much you'll
trust them even more and the whole time
right in certain cases they will be
basically like you mentioned profiting
off of us because they make us think we
have a problem we pay them money to fix
our problem and then
you know they basically the cycle
continues it's voila it's crazy but they
could only do this to this people who
are unknowledgeable
for who are followers you
convince a group of leaders to fall for
this type of rhetoric you can only
convince a group of followers to do that
and we live as a society full of
followers right people just follow one
another instead of leading by example
right and you mentioned a very very
interesting point right what so it's
actually one of the attendance of
Freemasonry it's called order out of
chaos order out of chaos right so they
cause the chaos and then they create the
order out of chaos one of the examples I
could give you is Imagine
um uh you know this so people understand
a little bit more clearly right imagine
a man kidnaps a woman right and the
whole time he's he he he's covering his
face the entire time right and he's
torturing her he's doing all this to the
woman and suddenly at the very end he
comes in and pretends that he's the one
who saved her he shows his face I'm the
one who saved you now she's gonna say oh
I owe my life to you but the whole time
he's the same one who kidnapped her and
tortured her the whole time it's a
different level of of like ecology where
you're really disrupting the mind and
this is what these people are
specialized in the people who are
deceiving the masses these people are
professional deceivers literally
professional deceivers they've mastered
the art of deception
subhanallah obviously Allah says that
the shaytan has a plan and Allah has a
plan and Allah is the best the plan is
I swear to God when you talk it's like
so many different light bulbs I know bro
I like it's so amazing actually actually
I think fired you mentioned this maybe a
few episodes ago
um where you basically asked the
question you know or you just point out
a fact you're like think about the fact
that there are people who work at Tick
Tock who dedicate their lives to
studying how to make you addicted to
their app
the same thing wrote TV everything if we
were good podcasters we'd be doing it
we'd be studying how to get people
hooked so they cannot leave now if you
do that with an Islamic Channel bro
keep going but when you do it for
something that's just feeding these
people a garbage 60 second videos of
someone doing a stupid impression of Jim
Carrey or whatever it's like
I you know actually also on the side
note think can you remember the last
three tick tocks you watch everyone can
you remember the last few tick tocks you
watch if not delete the app bro don't
watch anything because that's what it
does to you bro although that's what it
puts you in a state of just pure like
delusion and then you forget all about
it Allah go spend the time you spend on
Tick Tock doing what brother
Abdul wahab was talking about educating
yourself and not being someone who just
you know listens to other people and and
myself the slave mind everything 100
Allah and this is the saddest part you
know Allah created us with the capacity
and even in the Quran Allah appeals to
our our wisdom our knowledge our
intellect our logic our rationality
Allah appeals to it you know even Allah
asking do do they think they were
created from nothing
you know two I'm playing on my freaking
uh iPad right now I don't need I don't
have time to think about where I came
from excuse me
and if you're thinking oh I don't say
that okay but I mean you're living it
you're sitting you're watching you're
playing and you're not you're not
actually thinking about
you know this iPad had a creator
this couch I'm sitting on how to create
her the food I'm eating it came from the
earth and so on and so forth where did I
come from those are big big questions
subhanallah and they will always lead
you to Islam but as long as you know
it's very interesting that you mentioned
that because a lot of people they don't
ask themselves these questions until
their life slows down or until they end
up in jail right because on purpose you
have to understand like I said you have
to know your enemy in order to defeat
the enemy they purposely made our
lifestyle so quick so fast so we're not
able to ponder on the things that are
important right you have to understand
why entertainment all these distractions
were made in the first place is to keep
you away to keep you away from your
purpose of life right and this is
actually one of the things I studied in
the beginning like when I wanted to
study I was trying to find out the truth
I wanted to uncover all the different
truths of the world so I went on almost
a 10-year journey of trying to uncover
different not just about Islam but you
know I study all the different religions
all the satanic religions I studied
witchcraft so I could understand what
the people on the upper aside as well
what do they do what do they believe
right and it's very very interesting
because like the mentalities that they
have right the the tactics that they use
to bring people to them we can I
actually use a lot of their tactics to
bring people to Allah you know
so you know because usually if you look
at like the people the the like the the
devilish people or the people who
promote
um you know the the misguidance they
usually come in beautiful clothes they
look nice they have speech that sounds
like gold but when you get close to it
you find out it's bronze right but why
not use their tactics but have a message
that is pure gold right so it's kind of
like you know so it's like like it's
just like we have to think outside of
the box you know just kind of like think
outside the box I wanted to say
something else but I kind of lost my
train of thought in the middle of as I
was saying it what did you say right
before that because I I wanted to say
something regarding that
right before which statement yeah right
before right before
it's all good the thought Slipped Away
you don't like when you have
the more you think about it the more
it's running away from you yeah yeah
yeah bro that's me every single podcast
I have like 50 thoughts and then I
forget like 90 of them
well I just had another thought that I
forgot go ahead
I wish I could bro
[Laughter]
no no but I absolutely man honestly it's
it's a it's a great honor man it's a
great honor to know that you know
alhamdulillah you know that Allah has
chosen us to to give and to share The
Message of Islam man there's no more
beautiful job than this you know to
share the message of the truth and we're
truly saving people bro we're truly
saving people's lives we're saving
people's Souls actually you know I think
I remember what you were talking about
now because you're talking about the
people who they're so distracted they
don't think they don't have any time to
ponder to be honest a lot of these
people you have to understand that
they've been programmed into their
lifestyle their parents are are are are
programmed and they're also producing
children that are also programmed you
know so you know how it says in through
Yasin right
I believe uh it says Bismillah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
more one it says in the name of Allah
the most compassionate and most merciful
right Yasin by the Quran rich in wisdom
you will Prophet are truly one of the
messengers upon the straight path this
is a revelation from the almighty most
merciful so you may warn a people whose
forefathers were not warned and are so
heedless we're dealing with a bunch of
people who their Pharaoh their fathers
and their fathers were never warned of
the truth so now it is Our obligation if
we come face to face with one of their
one of these individuals we cannot let
them go by without them hearing The
Message of Islam hearing the truth so
now they have the opportunity to
contemplate and change the entire uh the
entire Dynamic of their future children
you know because you have to understand
you know these different brothers and
the Pharaohs that took shahada it's not
that they're just taking shahada we're
creating a fat new Muslim families bro
because they're gonna have they're gonna
get why they're gonna have children
their children are gonna have children
like it's bigger than we think it is bro
it's way bigger than we think if we if
you really think about it in a very deep
manner this is the most beautiful work
any human being can be involved in this
is the work of the prophets bro there's
no better work than this bro and we need
to start taking pride in in our religion
bro we need to be unapologetically
Muslim Unapologetic we should be proud
that we are Muslim and we need to take
control of The Narrative of Islam with
platforms like ours alhamdulillah you
guys have an amazing platform a lot of
our Muslim Brothers have good nice
platforms and we need to take charge of
The Narrative of Islam that's being sued
yeah bro see we have we have a friend
who's also on Tick Tock his name is
Riyad and he made this video Once Upon a
Time I Think Romney saw it too and he
says that you know one of the main
missions kind of proponent propagating
why he does what he does is because
everything that most people today that
lame and non-muslims know about Islam is
from the non-muslims so he's like why
don't why don't we start channels and
platforms where we teach them Islam from
a real Muslim the way Islam is supposed
to be not through non-muslims not
through the media
absolutely and you guys are doing
amazing and may Allah bless you guys may
Allah reward you guys may Allah give you
guys more success more Buttercup and
everything Allah grants you times a
million inshallah Allah I mean Allah you
want to answer this question bro Adam
writes how old is the Warner
so I just turned 30. I just turned 30
this month
I'm a young Soldier man I'm a young man
yeah bro never would have guessed bro
you look like you're in mid-20s bro yeah
man yeah
many many more strong years I mean I
mean I mean just turned 36. really
he's a joke I'm 22 alhamdulillah
she's young bro
um but
speaking of 36
so let's subtract 10 26. I actually want
to talk about 26th chapter of the Quran
because of what you said subhanallah
it reminded me of these verses so first
this actually because it also links to
what I forgot I wanted to say before but
I remember that Islam is so logical so
concise so clear and does not take much
thinking so much so to the point that
that is I think I've gotten just two
strictly logical and they've forgotten a
whole side of dawa which is emotional
intelligence it's being able to go to
someone see that state that they're in
and give them exactly what they need for
them to realize I have this issue in my
life Islam provides that solution
subhanallah and
when you give dawah in a way and
sometimes the answer is logic 100
sometimes
they need to like let's say you're
you're talking someone who worships an
idol right which is similar to what I'm
going to mention you can go to them and
just like the prophets in the Quran say
to them what does this bring to you
how's it given you food has it given you
drink like it doesn't give you anything
it's it's I can destroy it right now and
it would become rubble and I can like
use it and throw it like in my lawn
it won't benefit anything
so if you look at chapter 26 in the
Quran Allah
he tells us basically to relate or to
recite the story of Ibrahim when he went
to his his father and his people and he
asked you know what is it that you
worship besides Allah
and then they said you know we worship
idols and we're fully devoted like they
know they know what he's up to right
then they know why he's asking it's
rhetorical so he's like we worship idols
and we're devoted to them okay so we're
happy with what we have and then he asks
uh can they hear you when you call upon
them
or can can they benefit you or can they
harm you and they said no but we found
our forefathers doing the same
subhanallah exactly what you said
parents teaching their kids just to be
followers and they teach their kids just
to be followers and they imagine like
generation after generation worshiping
Idols worshiping Stones just because
their parents told them to right imagine
how devastating it is when your parents
teach you capitalism and consumerism and
these all these ideologies man man to
unpack that subhanallah
you need to hit them where it hurts you
need to hit them in the heart
emotionally this this is something we
can talk about on another episode too
but a lot of parents too I see where
they're coming from bro the way they try
to program and condition their kids too
is because for them it really was sink
or swim you know what I mean a lot of
immigrant parents too when they came
here they kind of glorified the idea of
money and then security and all this
type of stuff so they try to kind of
keep kids a little bit in the show you
know what I mean a little bit in in a
confinement in a safety net you know you
you want to say something that is the
truth but it's a little too
controversial don't say you know you
want to stand up for the dean oh but it
might put your life on the line don't
say it bro you know what I mean and we
got to understand we gotta have sympathy
with these parents too where they're
coming from because they're coming from
a place so just just genuinely looking
out for people but understand too bro
the best of Creation The Prophet saw
some was slandered was persecuted was
attacked was poisoned even I don't know
how authentic that is but I'm not a
scholar but poisoned what makes us think
us laymen are immune to that bro what
really gives us the audacity to think
that we should have it any easier
yeah 100 giving giving dawa is hard but
you know if actually Sheikh also was
talking about this I think a while ago
if you look at the process of in his
life you know when jabriel Ali came to
him he was like panicking right and he
went to his his wife
and said you know covering me cover me
and this happened two or three times
maybe and and each time it happened
Allah revealed the verses you know
um basically
um
you I think I don't know the translation
exactly but you who's covered up he says
Get Up In Her Eyes he's like you're in a
state of comfort
get up and go warn people he's panicking
Allah says get up and go warn people and
after warning people all day come and
worship Allah for a part of the night
subhanallah even when you're that kind
of infers that when you're in a state of
of just being comfortable all the time
are you really you have to ask yourself
are you really doing the work of Allah
if you're just sitting there comfortably
you know relaxing you don't have any
stress you you know you're just chilling
80 years of your life look back your
life what did you actually do with the
sake of Allah if you didn't struggle at
all
so I think that's a good point you made
mashallah bro well we're no one no we're
no one we're going to be criticized but
we're going to make mistakes well that's
the thing we we will make mistakes and
we'll be criticized for the mistakes and
we will speak the truth we'll be
criticized for speaking the truth at the
end of the day if you're doing it for
the sake of Allah you'll be good you
know what gives
one you know obviously when it comes to
the stuff because bro also see living in
Los Angeles Living in America doing what
I'm doing bro like especially as it gets
bigger I'm going to be dealing with a
lot of issues bro like I'm already bro I
see the shaitaan coming at me at
different angles every single time I go
out there I notice there's a different
obstacle that shaytan puts my way I
remember about three weeks ago there was
about 15 cops that pulled up on me and
surrounded me bro literally surrounded
me because I'm sharing The Message of
Islam and I know what's happening I'm
looking at them right I I know exactly
who's whispering in their ears bro I
know exactly what's going on right I'm
aware of this even though they're
unaware of what's going on but guess
what Allah says in the Quran those who
believe have nothing to fear and nor
will they ever grieve and I trust Allah
with all of my heart so I know if I am
doing the right thing and I'm doing what
Allah has told me to do I don't care
what happens to me I belong to Allah and
to Allah I will return I don't care
which way I return but to Allah will
return I'm ready to give my life for
this bro I'm ready to give my life for
this bro inshallah
with this being said Rami we gotta go
pray Maghrib right it sucks it sucks
that it's come to this brother we got a
wrap up the stream brother Abdul but it
definitely makes me look forward to part
two and many more other segments with
you inshallah we can definitely get you
over here to Toronto and we do an
in-person thing in a few months
inshallah definitely going to send this
over to on home make sure he watches it
he usually always does the ones that he
can't come he always replace it by
himself and may Allah keep putting
buttock on your work keep keep you as a
lion of the ummah bro as like a modern
day uh you know kawam in the forest in
the Dallas so may Allah keep yourself I
mean
right now
yeah as far as I just want to give like
a little advice of like let's say if
anyone else out there wants to give
dollar right or anything like that I'm
gonna have I have some short advice to
give to the people who are out there
that do want to do this as well because
I I want to be an inspiration for the
normal guy the normal everyday Muslim
right because I'm a normal everyday
Muslim bro I'm nothing special I'm a
normal dude right I was born and raised
in L.A I just the first time I read the
Quran was like about 10 years ago bro so
there's people that have way more time
on me you know as far as more they know
there's so many people are way more
knowledgeable than me but the thing
about me is I act on what I know if I
know something I'm gonna actively try to
share it with as many people as I can so
I just want to share with people anybody
else that wants to do the dawa right
never fear Allah has your back and you
have to know what you're doing it for
and why you're doing it and to stay
genuine because people could feel when
you're lying to them or when you're
telling telling them the truth it's
extremely important to be as genuine as
possible and connect with the hearts of
the people if you can do that inshallah
people will listen people will gravitate
towards you because you are being
genuine especially in a land full of
fake people bro if you are genuine you
will find success
another thing I would recommend is go
and look at the stories of the prophets
right start from Adam find out who is
shaitaan who is Allah who are the Angels
who is Adam Alyssa how did we get here
start from the beginning start from the
very beginning understand how we came to
Earth in the first place it's important
for you to understand all these things
start from Adam then end at the prophet
Muhammad and also study the Christian
stories of the prophets as well so you
could see the difference between the
real stories of the prophets and then
the slandered version of the stories of
the prophets you know so
um yeah so I just wanted to say that
also um
you know I am actually looking for a
wife so sister send in the applications
each other
[Music]
listen listen I'm gonna promote that I
don't really care the fact that you
waited till the end shows how genuine
you are bro it's not like the first two
seconds my man's like bro I'm single but
listen Ladies If you're looking for six
one six two listen e6a bro
[Laughter]
have you
both I mean and anyone that made it this
far too we tagged them in the title of
this video go over to his channel
smash that subscribe button like all of
his videos support him he's doing work
that too many people are coward to do
bro listen it's one thing too and and
and again around me bro you know how
much work me you and Arnold put in
mashallah bless us but bro it's easy to
just turn on our computers bro you know
a lot of people that that gotta you know
go outside set up these Stars set up
these boots in person bro that's that's
that's a whole nother level bro and you
know we've done three dollar bro we know
it's not easy you know so Miller blessed
brother wonderful keep keep on doing
what he's doing and uh make sure you
guys subscribe to our Channel inshallah
inshallah
everyone for attending
for joining us honestly amazing episode
and I pray to Allah that he grants us
many many more with you we have one
Super Chat
coming in
uh saying I saw a video of a guy
becoming Muslim thanks to Dawn maybe you
can react to all that's very interesting
we'll look into it and with that being
said
let's go let's go
oh